hey this is preshtalwalka reminding you
to mind your decisions
a rectangle contains three identical
circles as shown in the diagram
the top two circles are tangent to two
sides of the rectangle while the bottom
circle is tangent to just one side
if each circle has a radius of r
what is the area of the rectangle in
terms of r
this problem is adapted from one of the
hardest gcse exam problems
you can pause the video right now if
you'd like to give it a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video to
check your answer or to learn how to
solve this problem
[Music]
so to get the area of this rectangle we
want to solve for the length and the
width
we can solve for one dimension by
drawing in these radii of the circles
we see that this side of the rectangle
will be the sum of these lengths which
is 4r
now let's calculate the length of the
other side
we'll draw in the radii of these circles
and notice we're going to form an
equilateral triangle with a side length
of 2r
this means each angle is equal to 60
degrees we now draw an altitude as
follows
this divides the equilateral triangle
into two equal triangles that are 30 60
and 90. this is a special right triangle
the side opposite 30 degrees is r so the
site opposite 60 degrees will be r times
the square root of 3. you could have
also solved that using the pythagorean
theorem
this means this vertical length will be
r times the square root of 3.
to get the remaining length we draw in
these radii which have a length of r
so the total length of this side will be
the sum of these values which is equal
to r times the quantity 2 plus the
square root of 3.
we can then calculate the area as the
product of these two dimensions
and this gives us our answer of 4r
squared multiplied by the quantity two
plus the square root of three
incredible
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]